was für ein riesenschiff
für viele ist es ein traum auf der meyer
werft zu arbeiten martin cornelius hat
es geschafft seit september ist er dabei
in jeweiligen abteilung zu 17 jahre ist
er alt und er konnte es gar nicht
erwarten endlich seine ausbildung zu
beginnen
zwei dinge musste er gleich am anfang
lernen
erstens helm und schutzbrille sind
pflicht und zweitens die werft ist ein
sehr großer betrieb mit sehr langen
wegen
körperliche fitness muss man schon
mitbringen die hallen sind hunderte
meter lang hier bauen sie ein jahr lang
die schiffe zusammen bevor sie dann raus
in den hafen gezogen werden
als erstes geht er zu seinem meister
dreieinhalb jahre dauert die ausbildung
martin cornelius ist bereits im zweiten
lehrjahr im ersten hat er auf der
berufsschule die grundlagen gelernt so
große schiffe die auf der meyer werft zu
bauen das geht nur stück für stück die
arbeit teilt sich in einzelne
schiffsglocke auf die später
zusammengefügt werden und eine ganz
wichtige rolle spielen dabei die
sogenannten konstruktionsmechaniker das
ist der beruf den marken cornelius lernt
er wird später für den innenausbau dass
schiffe zuständig sein
ein sehr vielseitiger job den nicht
jeder machen kann
der ausbildungsleiter halb vor 28 jahren
selbst zu eine lehre abgeschlossen
und dann natürlich die persönlichkeit
von den jungen menschen muss passiert
martin cornelius ist einer von 270
auszubildenden in der mittagspause
wollen natürlich alle kollegen von ihm
wissen bei welchen bereichen ihnen das
fernsehen über die schulter gut
wir müssen noch auf schiffs sagt er und
dass daten nicht jeder draußen stehen
sie schlange
jeder der auf schiffl wird registriert
die meyer werft hat sich auf den bau von
kreuzfahrtschiffen spezialisiert dieses
hier steht kurz vor der auslieferung
und obwohl der auszubildende im zweiten
lehrjahr schon 970 euro pro monat
verdient wird er sich einen
karibikurlaub auf diesem luxusschiff
super nicht leisten können
dafür muss er zusehen dass er fit bleibt
denn die werft baut immer größere
schiffe in immer kürzerer zeit der
ausbildung heißt es natürlich auch das
sind auszubildende belastbar sein muss
auch unter ständigem zeitdruck arbeiten
muss und wachstumsgeschwindigkeit nicht
den anschluss verlieren darf früher
haben sie für so ein schiff zwei jahre
gebraucht jetzt schaffen sich in einem
auch deshalb haben die azubis eine
perspektive aber die übernahme schauen
sich sehr gut hier bei der firma denn
die auftragsbücher sind auf jahre voll
im herbst soll schon das nächste
kreuzfahrt schiffe fertiggestellt werden